now this is a first two coffins arriving  back at Surabaya airbase we know now  that the 162 passengers on board that  AirAsia QZ 8501 sadly have all perished  these are the first two coffins arriving  back being brought home  well that took flight from Surabaya to  Singapore went missing as we know as it  was flying over the Java Sea between the  islands of belitung and Borneo yesterday  we'll show you various pieces of  wreckage that were found in the sea the  emergency chute and also life jackets  and today it's been confirmed that at  least one body was wearing a life jacket  when it was found suggesting that the  crew and passengers were aware that they  were in difficulty before the aircraft  came down